the world is will set in the future the  world at war the environments being  being completely changed and we have  these huge predator cities the big  cities are on wheels and they they eat  up smaller towns that can't get on  wheels you have these all these really  interesting characters and the first one  we get to know is is has to show who is  this girl who's on a mission to kill the  man who murdered her mother a film is  visually lush stunning and immersive his  tailor made for I meant it's unlike  anything you've seen before we watched  it for the London premiere on the big  huge IMAX screen in Leicester Square the  screen in London is the size of four  double-decker buses you go in there you  go now I realize why people pay the  ticket yeah I mean it's enormous  so yeah it'd be it would be kind of  cheating yourself if you watched it on  your phone or something you need to see  it on the biggest screen possible you  know that's IMAX